bueno pues después de haber estado
trabajando con los vídeos de por qué
hacemos las mismas cosas de ambos lados
y después de haber estado trabajando con
la idea de la balanza en este vídeo lo
que vamos a hacer son algunos ejemplos
entonces vamos a empezar por este que
dice x voy a cambiar de color porque
este como que no me gustó a ver vamos a
cambiar de color ok ya tengo un color
entonces éste dice x + 7 es igual a 10
entonces otra vez lo que voy a hacer es
restar 7 de ambos lados y entonces de
este lado restó 7 de este lado resto 7 y
entonces como estamos haciendo lo mismo
de ambos lados ahora vamos a resolver en
x 7 menos 7 pues resulta que esto se
cancela y sólo me queda x
y de este lado 10 menos 7 me queda 3 en
como hemos estado haciendo lo mismo de
ambos lados entonces x es igual a 3
vamos con otro ejercicio este otro dice
algo así como
- 5
es igual a menos 2 bueno lo que tiene de
interesante este ejercicio es que tiene
números negativos en ambos lados pero
vamos a proceder de una manera muy
semejante entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es sumar 5 en ambos lados
y sumó 5 y ahora vamos a resolver
entonces de este lado a 5 menos 5 pues
se cancelan estos dos y sólo me queda a
y de este lado menos 25 es igual a 3 y
entonces otra vez como hicimos lo mismo
de ambos lados entonces a es igual a 3
nos vemos en el próximo vídeo